more
um so today's topics are going to be
privacy and then or rather minimax rates
um under privacy constraints
then a little bit about computation
constraints
so for privacy the references are
acharya
sun
and jung
differentially private
aswad
paper from 2020 and the second one is by
duchy jordan and wainwright
it's called minimax optimal procedures
for locally private estimation
and it was published in 2018 but i think
it's actually from 2013.
so historically the second paper
is several years before the first one
but the first one focuses on the general
setting of what's called epsilon delta
differential privacy whereas the second
one focuses on local differential
privacy so that's why i'll talk about
the first paper first and
actually i might end up spending most of
the time talking about the results in
the first paper but we'll see how time
goes
so let's begin with some
reminder definitions about differential
privacy
okay so
the standard definition of differential
privacy is the following
let script x
denote the underlying
data domain
of individual data samples
and a randomized estimator
theta hat which maps
script x to the n
so we have n data points to theta
satisfies what's called epsilon
differential privacy
which we'll also abbreviate by epsilon
dp
if
for all subsets s of capital theta
and all
data points
x or data sets
x y and script
x to the n
with hamming distance
1 we have probability theta hat of x is
in s
is less than or equal to
e to the epsilon times probability
that
theta hat i'm sorry
theta hat of y is in s
okay so um differential privacy is sort
of inherently
a probabilistic
uh
a probabilistic definition um so we can
think about theta hat as some randomized
algorithm and in practice
you can think about it as some i mean in
some settings you might take an
empirical mean of the data and add some
noise to it for instance
um
and what we want to do is we want to
guarantee that
that the probability that the output of
the algorithm is in some set s
doesn't change too much if we just
perturb one point so that's what it
means for x and y to be of hamming
distance one
so it's also some notion of stability of
the of the algorithm
and there's also a version of
differential privacy that's called
epsilon delta differential privacy and
maybe i'll just um write it here so
um
so we're not going to talk about this
because it just makes things more
complicated
but there are in fact results under
epsilon different epsilon delta
differential privacy
um in this work so epsilon
epsilon delta differential privacy is
where you also have an extra term delta
there so there's an additive term that
gives you a little bit more slack
um so we're interested in minimax risk
under um the constraint that an
estimator is differentially private so
just to make this explicit
um
so for a collection of distributions
that's the definition for a collection
of distributions t
we want to characterize
the minimax risk which we'll write as r
sub dp for differential privacy of
p l epsilon
which is the enthemum over let's say
theta hat is epsilon differentially
private
supremum over
distributions p and script p
expectation x distributed as um p to the
n
l of theta hat of x
theta of p so this is using the same
notation that we had last time let me
just note here that here we're assuming
that we have n iid data points
okay so we'll be constructing an
estimator based on an iid data points
and just to remind you at the very
beginning of
the first lecture we were working under
a setting where x could come from a
general distribution
but throughout this work we'll assume
that our data are id
um okay so
maybe just a quick remark
is that
the the usual minimax risk
which i guess i didn't denote as
anything um so usual
non-private
minimax risk
is always a lower bound
for r so dp
pl epsilon so i'm just stating the
obvious
and this is
simply because we're we're restricting
to a class of estimators theta hat so of
course the entroma will be at least as
large as it would have been with no
restriction and we'll use that in in
some of the lower bounds
okay
um so
now what i'm going to give is a
differential for differentially private
version of thanos method
okay so this is pronounced method for
differential privacy and we have the
following theorem and this is from the
paper by acharya at all
so let's script v be equal to
a set of distributions which is a subset
of script p
and let this be such that
for all i not equal to j
we have two conditions
so the first one is that
we have some notion of separation
theta of
p i
theta of p j
is bigger than or equal to two delta
and the second one is that the total
variation distance between pi
and pj is at most gamma
i forgot to mention that we're going to
use the same convention as earlier and
we're going to assume that this l here
is equal to oops sorry hit the wrong
button um is equal to phi composed with
row so as before row is the semi-metric
fee is the increasing function
um so we need just as in
in the earlier development of final we
need two delta separation in
in the row metric
and now we're instead of this
mutual information or kl divergence
upper bound we're going to have a total
variation upper bound
um and and remember this is just on the
distribution of the of the data um
these are the distributions that are
generating the iid data points
and the conclusion is
then
r sub dp
of
script p l epsilon is bigger than or
equal to
some constant times phi of 2 delta
times the minimum
of 1 and
m over
e to the 10 epsilon and gamma
okay so we have this lower bound um and
of course as in the case of the usual
final there's some prefactor that
depends on delta
there's also a dependence on on how
large a set we can have uh two delta's
separated set um we see this uh but the
difference here is that um before we had
an upper bound on um something like kl
divergence and here we have an upper
bound on tv and that shows up down below
in the denominator
and
in practice um the game we would play is
kind of like in the in the usual final
method we would try to lower bound this
stuff by some constant
okay so um we would maybe i should write
this a bit more carefully um
so
let's
do this so what we would want to do is
um is is construct p one up to p p m
then
choose delta
such that
or yeah okay so choose delta and the
packing set
p1 up to
pm such that this is
bigger than or equal to some constant
okay so i guess there's not explicitly a
dependence here on delta but everything
is of course all connected to each other
and you'll see this in the in the
examples
or in the one example
okay um
so now let's go to a discussion of the
proof i think i'll go through most of
the details
okay so the the main um the main
statement or one one useful statement um
which i'm not going to prove is
the following so
one can show
that
under condition b
there exists a coupling
x y
between
the n fold product distributions p i to
the n
and p pj to the n
such that the expected hamming distance
between x and y
is equal to n times the total variation
distance between p i and p j
which is then going to be less than or
equal to n gamma because our assumption
is that we have this upper bound on the
tv distance okay so so really as we'll
see um what we need in order to have
guarantees for differentially private
algorithms
is some control of what the hamming
distance is and this sort of makes sense
because um differential privacy tells us
how an estimator behaves when we when we
change one item of the data set and if
the hamming distance is bounded by n
gamma then really we have a bound that's
something like well whatever we we
incurred every time we changed one
element of the data set and then and
iterated and gamma times
um so
let's keep going um
so just to uh to commemorate this event
um so by markov's inequality
we then have probability that the having
distance between x and y is bigger than
10 and gamma will be at most
at most 1 over 10
so let e be the high probability event
so this is going to be the event that
the hamming distance is less than or
equal to 10 and gamma okay so let's save
that for later
all right um so now note that
for any
differentially private estimator
theta hat x
if we define the production estimator
p hat of x is equal to the argument
over all p in our
set
of
rho of
theta of p
theta hat of x
then
the triangle inequality
implies that we have the following bound
rho of
theta of p hat
theta of p
is less than or equal to rho of theta of
p hat
theta hat of x
plus rho of theta of p
theta hat of x
which is bounded by twice rho of theta
of p theta hat of x
okay so what's going on here um
so if you remember when we proved fano's
inequality before
um or finals method before we we dealt
with the sort of projection estimator
although it wasn't exactly called that
so just um
i think what we
so earlier let's write this in red
we defined something like um i think it
was
psi of x was the
arg min over all the indices
um
rho of
theta hat of x um pi i think that's what
it was
um and and now we're replacing it with
this which is mapping um uh
which is which is giving us the the
actual it's only the actual distribution
which is the closest um to two theta hat
of x so to draw a picture like we had in
the last lecture
um we have this uh well we have this
maybe i'll do this in black we have
these points
that correspond to beta of p1 theta of
p2
up to theta of pm and we know that by
construction these are all two deltas
separated
um and then what we what we see is theta
hat of
x
okay and we look at the closest guy in
row distance
so in this case uh p hat of x
would be equal to p2
okay so we're just sort of mapping
things to the closest guy and just for
bookkeeping purposes rather than
picking out the index in this case 2 of
the closest theta we're actually picking
out what the p would be
now this inequality follows quite easily
so the first one is triangle inequality
and the second one is telling us that
well this quantity is the same as this
quantity and then by optimality of p hat
this quantity is also less than that
quantity
okay so what are we going to do with
this um well now we are going to start
playing around with um with expected
values and probabilities so
let's go back to
um
to the the notion to the expectation
that shows up in
in
in the min max risk so
you're right therefore
supremum over p in script p of
expectation x distributed as p to the n
of l of
theta hat of x theta p so this is what
we're interested in we're interested in
this quantity
where theta hat is a differentially
private estimator
well by markov's i'm sorry you know so
first we're going to
lower bound this fine average so this is
just like in the usual finals inequality
supremum is certainly
lower bounded by an average of
some specific instantiations which
correspond to
the the pi's that are in our set
okay
and then
now i'm going to take 1 over 2m so
um right up here we have
uh
we have an inequality that that relates
these guys to these guys so i'm going to
use that inequality here
this is greater than or equal to
sum
p and v
expectation under x distributed as p n
of
l of theta of p hat
theta of p okay so of course this
inequality here is in terms of the rows
but if we um
if we apply the the function um phi then
is that
true um
okay well
i will have to go back and look at this
myself um so certainly if there's no fee
function it is true um
so
uh so so if this uh
let me let me correct myself and then
maybe erase it okay so so if this were a
row instead um and if l were equal to
composition of v times rho and there
were no rho right then this would be a
row and i could certainly use
this
inequality up here to include this step
here
however if i try to
apply fee to both sides
then i may have a little bit of a
problem because 2 is showing up in the
wrong place
someone's telling me over a chat that
works if fee is increasing ah
i'm not sure if it works if he is
increasing okay well let me uh go back
and edit my notes later but to be honest
um the way that this was presented in
the paper there is no fee function and
the example we're going to use um
there's only a row so
so the
um
the
yeah later we're going to apply it where
where the loss function is just the
total variation distance and then we
don't need the presence of fee but when
i was preparing the lecture i thought it
would be nice if
okay the person who said that they
thought that it was
um immediate it said that maybe it's not
um okay so when i was preparing the
lecture i wanted to to prove this in as
much generality as i did in the earlier
parts
um so i added a fee and i think that
this might not immediately follow but
probably some version of this should
work if if the loss function is is fee
times rho um so maybe for now let's uh
assume that
l
is a semi-metric
so we'll assume that l is a semi-metric
and rigorously proceed
and i will look back and see if i can
fix this later
okay good so um
so assuming that this inequality holds
where rho is equal to l
then we can go from here to here because
we just take out a factor of 2.
good
and then what
so
now we're going to use markov's
inequality
and say that this is greater than or
equal to
[Music]
so now i'm going to drop all the fees
that i had earlier so let's say 2 delta
over 2m
sum p in script v
of
probability
under
x distributed as p to the s p to the n
of l of theta of p hat theta of p
bigger than or equal to
two delta
okay so this is just markov
and then this is equal to
delta over m times the sum
p in script v
uh probability
um
okay well i don't need that step let's
just say this is equal to this
probability
x is distributed as p to the n
um p hat of x is not equal to p
okay and why is this true um well
this is actually sort of obvious so
remember that um
that uh the
theta that p hat is going to be one of
the pi's
right or sorry one one of the one of the
p's that is that is in my
in my two delta separated set
and so theta of p hat is either going to
be equal to
theta of p or it's going to be something
that's um that's further away
okay let's
write this in words so
simply that the the set
row of theta of p hat
theta of p
less than 2 delta is exactly equal to
the
to the event that p hat is equal to p
okay so i mean you either map it to
something that's not p or you map it to
something that is p and if you map it
something that's not p then you go um
two delta away
okay good so now what do we want to do
um well we want to derive a lower bound
on this left hand side so it remains to
derive a lower bound on this guy
all right um
okay so there's a little bit more
manipulation here so
let beta i
be equal to the probability under x
distributed as t i
p hat of x is not equal to p
so we want to lower bound
the sum
i goes from one to m of beta i
okay
um
and so
if we if we do that then we'll lower
bound this guy as well all right um
so now for a fixed pair
p i p j
with i not equal to j
let x y
be the coupling
uh mentioned above
so it's this coupling so that the
hamming distance between x and y um is
going to be small with high probability
okay then we're going to write a little
bit more algebra
so 1 minus beta j so beta i is in words
it's the probability of error when we
draw our data from the distribution i
this is equal to
the probability
under y is distributed as p j
of p hat of y equals p j
okay so here just to
keep a little bit better track of the
notation
so
uh so x and y are denoted as p i and p j
so when i write out one minus beta j i'm
looking at the probability of being
correct when i'm drawing from
distribution j so that's why i'm putting
a y there
we can write this as a sum over states
little y
probability that y takes on
little y probability
um that p hat of
y
is equal to
pj
and now we're going to focus on when the
event
the high probability event holds and
when it doesn't okay so the high
probability event was denoted as e
this is when the hamming distance is
closed
um so we'll look at p of x comma y
probability that p hat of y equals p j
plus the sum
and now we just don't care when things
are not in e so we'll just have
probability of x y
um if you're following very closely
then you will wonder perhaps why there's
a probability here
here y is a particular instantiation of
the data
and you might wonder why there's even a
probabilistic statement and this is
because
well p hat depends on theta hat it's a
projection of of theta hat applied to
the data
and and theta hat itself is a randomized
algorithm through our definitions of
differential privacy
okay so
um if you're following thus far
um then what do we know well we know
that that this guy is
upper bounded by 0.9 because 0.1
because by our earlier
high probability event we had defined it
so that
the probability of e not happening was
bounded by 1 10.
okay so then this implies that
probability
that
the sum
x y and e p of x y
probability p hat of y
equals p pj is going to be at least 0.9
minus beta j
okay
[Music]
and then
we have
probability x distributed as p i of p
hat of x
equals p j so now this is the
probability of being incorrect
um so remember i is not equal to j so
we're saying that we're drawing the data
from i and we're
we're concluding that we have j
well this is bigger than or equal to the
sum over
xy and e
p of
xy probability that p hat of little x is
equal to pj so again i'm just now
summing over all the the possible
instantiations of the paris x y and i'm
ignoring the ones that aren't in e
and i have here um
so i have here a lower bound on
something that looks very similar right
i mean this sum looks almost like that
one
and the difference is that now instead
of y i have x
but now here is where
we use the fact that we have
differential privacy
so this is in turn bigger than or equal
to the sum over
x y and e
probability of x y
and here we have an e to the negative 10
epsilon n gamma
times probability
p hat of y is equal to pj
okay so what what have we done well
we've we've changed the x into the y and
we've used the fact that they're in e so
they're hamming distance at most um
at most 10 and gamma right and then by
differential privacy every time we
change one data point then we can change
the probabilities by most um e to the
negative epsilon
okay
so then um this is going to be bigger
than or equal to now using this bound
here bigger than or equal to
0.9 minus beta j
e to the negative 10 epsilon n gamma
okay so then the last manipulation
so remember we wanted to get a bound on
on the summation of beta i right we want
to get a bound on
um on this summation on the
probabilities of errors
instead we have here a lower bound
that looks like that so we just need to
rewrite things a little bit
so finally
we have um sum
i goes from 1 to m beta i which is equal
to the sum
i goes from 1 to m
probability under
x distributed as p i to the n of p hat
of x not equal to p i so that's just the
definition
and we can write this as a double sum
sum over i goes from 1 to m
and some j is not equal to i probability
x distributed as p i to the n
p hat of x is equal to p j
we're writing it like this because we
want to invoke this guy there
and this is going to be bigger than or
equal to the sum so if we sort of switch
things around
j goes from 1 to m
times the probability that we're not
equal
and we'll we'll be summing up the same
lower bound here m minus 1 times
so we end up with this times 0.9 minus
beta j
times e to the negative 10 epsilon and
gamma
okay so now we have this summation of
beta i on one side and we sort of have
the summation of beta i again and if we
rearrange then we end up with the final
result
so
rearranging
gives the desired
lower bound on summation of bi
implying the result
okay
so it was a bunch of manipulation so
let's just go back and review what we've
learned or what was happening here
um so we go back to the theorem
and uh
so
well if you
with my with my edits i guess this is
now going to be replaced by row but i'll
go back and see whether something more
general can be said
um so what we what we did was we saw
that if we had a two delta separated set
in in the row semi-metric and we had
total variation distance of pairs
bounded by gamma then we could use the
fact that um
that there's
well with high probability there's
there's a coupling such that with high
probability x and y are close to each
other
um and we can use that then to to deal
with these probabilities of error that
show up um in
in applying um the the usual lower
bounding techniques for the um
for the quantity here that's showing up
in minimax risk
okay so let's um forge ahead and discuss
an example where we're going to use this
um so the example that we'll look at
is for k-ary distribution estimation
okay
so
consider the problem
of estimating a density
of a distribution supported on
k points
one up to k
and
let script p
be the
k dimensional probability simplex
and suppose
l which is now equal to rho
is the
i'll just write it like this suppose l
is the tv distance
okay and so in particular
l is a semi-metric
so we can ignore
c so even if there's not an easy fix to
um to the manipulations i was trying to
do above that's okay we can still apply
the theorem and
not be missing any rigor here
okay so we will show
that the
differential differentially private min
max risk
is
lower bounded by order of square root of
k over n
max with k over n epsilon
provided k is bounded by some constant
times and epsilon
using fano's method
okay
so
here you see that we have a max between
two quantities one of them involves the
privacy parameter and one doesn't
um and this isn't this looks a bit like
the types of rates that we saw in the
robustness lecture where we had one part
that depend on the problem parameters
and one part that depended on
how much noise we wanted to be robust to
and this is no accident really the first
bound can be obtained using the usual
thanos method um with no privacy
constraints because as we said that's
always a lower bound on our differential
privacy
and then the second one can be obtained
using the method that i just described
of course even for the usual finos
method you need to construct some sort
of well separated set and we'll use the
same separated set with slightly
different parameters to to get both
lower bounds
so let's see how this works um
so we will use the following lemma
so here's a another result from quoting
theory um
and this lemma
says that
um
let 20 less than or equal to l less than
or equal to k over 2
be an integer
then there exists a constant weight
binary code
c
of length k
such that
sorry of length k
weight l
and minimum distance
l over 4
with the cardinality of c being at least
k over 2 to the 7 8 l
to the power
7 l over 8. so we're not going to prove
this um what does this mean
so we have a binary code so the values
are are zero and one
length k
weight l means that the total number of
ones in each of the
code words is equal to l and then it's
going to be separated every every two
code words have hamming distance of at
least l over four
um
so we're going to apply this result
so
we will
apply the lemma
with l equals k over 2.
okay
so
i guess for this technically for this
result to hold we'll need k to be at
least 40.
so we'll say that this lower bound
should hold as long as k is larger than
some constant
um
okay so
suppose so we're gonna go about and
construct our two delta separated set
based on on such a set of codes
so suppose delta is less than 116.
so delta is the parameter we're going to
play with later to balance things out
now for each
c in the code
word in the code book
we define
the k area distribution
with
pc of i so we're defining a density on
i
points
so it's 1 plus 16 delta over k
if ci is equal to 1 and 1 minus 16 delta
over k
if ci is equal to 0 okay so we have of
course
c is going to be equal to some binary
string
and
and this is just telling us that on
average
all of the all the points
well
the density that we have for every
all the k values is one over k but then
we have a little bias upward and a
little bias downward
okay
and um and this actually defines a
density it integrates to one because
we're using l equals k over two right so
l equals k over 2 means that well the
weight is is l so that means that every
code has exactly as many the same number
of ones as zeros and i guess it actually
works in this case um okay so
uh so we define this density um
and we have the whole code book script c
so we end up with a whole bunch of
different densities and now we want to
show that these are in fact going to be
two delta separated and also that we
have an upper bound and total variation
distance
um
okay
oh uh so someone asked on on the zoom is
it easy to calculate um differentially
private estimators that match the risk
bound
so i forgot to mention it um before i
uh i dug into the proof or so usually
the pattern that i've been doing where
i've been discussing these results is
that first i state the lower bound and
then i say it can be achieved
so let me just put a note here this can
be achieved using what's called a
laplace mechanism
okay so following the pattern of not
going into detail about anything with
upper bounds let me just say that
laplace mechanism is where you add
laplace noise um to to an estimator um
in various ways in order to make it
differentially private so what you do is
you look at the histogram of your data
and then you add some noise to it
according to the laplace mechanism
so yes it can be achieved
um
okay so going back to this construction
so now we need to check that we have a
two delta separated set
um
so
of course um let our set be equal to
pc such that c is in script c
then for c not equal to c prime
we have so we need to show separation in
row metric our row metric is total
variation distance and we need to look
at pc and pc prime
and this is equal to so for discrete
distributions it's just one half the l
one distance
i goes from one to k
um pc of i minus pc prime of i
and
then you can just sort of look at the
separation between the um the two
distributions and i believe you'll get
one half times 32 delta over k times k
over eight
um
and this is all coming from the fact
that well the one half is of course the
one half there um and then whenever the
coordinates differ um the difference
between pci and pc prime i is going to
be um twice of 16 delta over k which is
this guy and then the minimum distance
is at least l over 4 l was k over 2 so
we get that okay so we defined
everything of course so that this would
be exactly equal to delta
good so we have two delta separation but
now we also need an upper bound on total
variation unfortunately that's also easy
so we also have total variation between
pc and pc prime is upper bounded by
one half times 32 delta over k
times k and where is this coming from
well again whenever the coordinates
differ
they differ by 32 delta over k and the
length of the codes is k so they can
differ in most k components
and this is equal to 16 delta which
we'll define as gamma because we wanted
an upper bound of gamma between pairs of
um i mean for the total variation
distance between pairs of distributions
okay so and then by the lemma
on how big this code book can be
we have
or we can choose
script v such that
log base 2 of m or just log of m is on
the order of
c times k so the dilemma tells us that
the size of the code book
is this so the log of that will have um
log we'll have seven l over eight which
is order of k
times the log of this guy of course k
and l are the same order so it's really
a constant times
it's log of a constant times
order k so that's why we have order c k
good so now we're ready to plug it into
our bound so
so the fano's method bound
then gives r sub dp of p
l epsilon is going to be order of
so um we have our delta so maybe i'll
just scroll up and remind you what the
bound look like
um
[Music]
so the bound said that we have um
we have some constant
um we have a delta and then we have a
min of one and m over this stuff okay so
let's go back down
so we have
this thing times minimum of 1 and we
have to look at
at m m is equal to
is on the order of um
ck uh and then we have um e to the n
10 and epsilon gamma
so
um so 10 n epsilon gamma becomes c prime
epsilon and delta
okay
and that's because um
delta was the same order as gamma okay
so we had
10 epsilon and gamma becomes 10 becomes
c prime epsilon n delta
okay so so as i said we want to choose
things um so that this this stuff
becomes a constant and clearly we we can
then choose delta to be on the order of
kappa of k over epsilon n
leading to
omega of k over epsilon n bound
okay and that's the bound that i claimed
from the beginning
now we need to get the other bound as
well so up above i also had
had an order of
root k root k over n which i said could
be used could be obtained using the
usual final bound
so
to obtain
the omega k over n
bound
from usual final
we will reuse the same construction
with a different
delta
okay
so um
so we're going to have the same
construction here
um
and we're just going to tweak the
the parameter that tells us how much we
change these distributions by
um so we have this two delta separation
so that's good we still have it
now what we need is a bound on the
pairwise kl divergences right because
that's what we have in instead of tv we
need kl
um so
so we have
or let's just say
for c not equal to c prime
we have kl divergence between
pc and pc prime um so this it turns out
the kl divergence is actually upper
bounded by what's called the chi-squared
divergence
and this can be written out quite nicely
as a sum i goes from 1 to k
p c i minus p c prime i squared
over p c prime i
and it turns out that this is
order of delta squared
so why does this make sense well
remember that the difference between the
coordinates when there is a difference
is on the order of delta
so really the the numerator is a sort of
order of of delta squared
and then for the denominator all of the
components are kind of roughly equal to
one over k
okay so
you can
you can show this and
then fano's method
gives
the bound
so we have omega of
well what should show up we should have
delta and we should also have one minus
the upper bound on the pairwise kl
divergences c times n times delta
squared because we have a product
distribution
plus one over um log of the size of the
of the of the packing set um remember
the size of the packing set was
log of m is is c times k so we have down
here c times k
and that means that if we want to make
this um
this stuff bigger than or equal to
one-half then we can
choose k to be choose delta
squared to be on the order of
um k over n
so we get to the bound of omega of root
k over n
okay so all is well
good um
okay so not surprisingly this took up um
a big part of the lecture so now i'm
going to
um say something about local
differential privacy
so my plan is to talk about this for um
let's say the next 15 minutes then we'll
have a break then i'll talk about local
local differential privacy for a bit
more time and then switch over to
computation because the computation
section is a little bit shorter than the
others
but i think i will probably still end up
skipping a bunch of details because
local differential privacy gets pretty
well it's pretty detailed heavy even in
the presentation i tried to put together
so what is local differential privacy um
so just a
sort of a brief motivation and a sketch
um
so
the setup of
um usual
dp
assumes that a central curator
collects
all data
x
and computes
theta hat
x
by adding noise or let's say by
randomization
okay so maybe the important part is the
central trusted curator
um
but individuals
all right let's just say
but
what if individuals
don't trust a central curator
um and are only willing to
release
a
noisy version
of their observations
of their data
okay so the picture to have in mind um
this is sort of graphical model speak so
you have your data sets your data points
x1 up to xn so these are what your
individuals have
um and they're they want to release some
version of
their data
zn so this is sort of the the privacy
wall they don't want anyone to see what
their x eyes are but they'll release
these zi's and then the um the
the estimator is going to be based on
the z i's
so
the final estimator is going to be some
theta hat of z1 up to zn
um the most general local differential
privacy
setting allows these these to depend on
each other
okay so
there's going to be possible
dependencies as you go along
um so let's give a
definition a more rigorous definition
so here's the definition
for a privacy
parameter
alpha bigger than or equal to zero
the random variable
zi is alpha locally differentially
private for x i
if for all possible z1 up to
z i minus one so those are the
previously released
observations
and for all x x prime
and x
these are possible values of x
we have supremum over
s in some sigma field over the space of
z q of
z i
in s
given x i
equals x
z 1 equals z 1 up to
z i minus 1 equals z i minus 1
divided by
the probability that z i is an s where
now we change the value of
x to x prime and everything else stays
the same
is bounded by
e to the alpha
okay and this is where
um
where this guy is an appropriate sigma
field
um and so this is what it means for um
for for zi to be a private view of x i
and then of course the algorithm is
going to be anything that operates on
the zi's
so an estimator
q of
z
is
i guess i mean
let's say theta
an estimator theta hat of q of z is
locally differentially private if each
zi is
alpha locally differentially private
okay
um
and so actually to make things simpler
um
oftentimes people focus on what's called
the non-interactive mechanism so a
non-interactive mechanism is where we
massively simplify this diagram and we
say well you know it's great that
that the individuals could use the
publicly released
zi's that have come before
to create their
their privatized versions but you know
why don't we just assume that
everything's independent okay and that
doesn't mean that that these guys are
necessarily iid you know the original
x's were iid and then we're just
generating some sort of noisy versions
um so this this version where the zi's
are are independent given the excise is
known as the non-interactive
non-interactive mechanic mechanisms
okay so the definition is
the definition here is
a non-interactive
estimator
satisfies
alpha locally differentially local
differential privacy if
the supremum over all s and the supremum
over
all x x prime
of now we just have to condition on
on
the value of x i
d i and s given x i equals x prime
is bounded by e to the alpha okay so
this looks a little bit this this
definition looks a little bit more like
the usual differential privacy right we
change one value and we don't want the
estimator to change too much so now we
change one value and we don't want the
corresponding z to change very much
um i'm not going to dwell on these
definitions much longer but let me just
say that you know after you've seen
these definitions you might wonder well
what's up with all this you know
possible dependencies um it makes
perfect sense that everyone just
generates their own data so um one
example of sequential mechanisms that
are studied are when these might
correspond to if you're trying to do
some sort of stochastic gradient descent
and each time you draw a new sample and
you use that for optimization so you
could think about the zi's as being
the the previous iterates so in order to
get the next iterate you draw the new
you draw a privatized version of the new
data but you use the previous iterates
to continue to update
um but let's not dwell on that so for
the results that i'm going to state and
use we'll focus on just
guarantees for non-interactive
mechanisms
okay so um
so now with a little bit of rotation let
script q sub alpha denote
the set
of
all conditional distributions
with
the
alpha locally differential private
property
and we can define the min max risk
as
r sub ldp
of p
l alpha so now our our privacy is uh is
parameterized by alpha rather than
epsilon this is going to be the infimum
over theta hat and over
q which is in this set of possible
conditional distributions q alpha
supremum
over
p in script p expectation over x
distributed as p n so we have iid data
and conditionals of z given x come from
q
and then we have a loss of theta hat of
z
let me move this over
right here
um comma theta of p
okay so let's just sort of stare at this
a moment so we have the loss function
applied to
to the thetas and now theta hat is a
function of z rather than x
we take an expectation with respect to x
as well as the way that we're generating
the z's from the x's we're allowed to
design
this channel q however we want to
generate z's from x's as well as the
estimated theta hat
okay
um
so
and maybe the one thing to remark is
that unlike in the usual privacy
in the bounds that we talked about
earlier with
not local but just epsilon differential
privacy in those cases the usual
non-private risk was a lower bound that
is no longer necessarily going to be the
case here right because now we have
estimated interest functions of z rather
than x so it's not like we're just
taking in femum over a smaller set like
we were doing in the case of
differential privacy constrained
estimators
okay and i should say that so this work
is that i'll mention is um is from duchy
at all's paper and they do study a
little bit non-interactive mechanisms as
well we're focusing here on interactive
mechanisms and final to to make this to
make the um explanation a bit a bit
simpler
so we're going to talk about fano's
method
um
so consider
of course a set of distributions
pv
such that v is in some script v which is
a subset of p
and
now
so now to make things even more
complicated um we will use a distance
based generalization
alfano's inequality
and rather than
having to construct
a two delta separated set
um
subset
of script p
we can let or we will let
script v be an arbitrary
finite set
um
okay
or i guess what i mean is um is we'll
let
uh
this guy the set of of pvs be an
arbitrary set
okay so so this is pv such that um
v is in script v okay so so we're going
to
to to state a bound that will work even
if um these uh these tvs are not too
delta separated but then of course we
need to correct some of the other terms
that show up in the bound
um
so
uh this is based on
a version of fano's inequality
that
replaces
that replaces
the error probabilities
which we saw in the first lecture
probability that x comes from pv
to the n
psi of x is not equal to v
by tail probabilities
probability x comes from pv to the n
rho
v
psi of x
v
is bigger than t
for
some metric
on
for some metric
row v on the set v
okay
so um so this is not something that's
specific to
differential privacy this is just
another version of a lower bound you
could prove that generalizes fano's
lower bound
and i'm being a bit loose when i say
fano's method versus thanos inequality
if you remember
fano's method for minimax lower bounds
depends on turning things into a
decoding problem and then what shows up
is these sorts of quantities what's the
probability that i um that my my
detector chooses the wrong thing when
the data come from b
so there's um and sofano's inequality
the usual funnels inequality gives a
lower bound for this
there's also a version that you could
derive where
instead of of these inequalities
you look at at something in terms of the
probability that the distance is bigger
than t now in the case when t is equal
to zero
then um this is going to be exactly
equal to the probability of being wrong
okay but um we can
write okay so uh so just a little bit
more notation
um
so for each t bigger than zero
define the neighborhood size
find the
neighborhood size which is
nt is defined as the max
over v in script v
of
the size of the set v prime in v
such that rho v of v prime is less than
or equal to t so let me just write these
things out and you can stare at them
and the separation function
delta of t is equal to
one-half
minimum of
rho of theta of pv
theta of pv prime
such that v and v-prime are in script v
and rho sub v of v v prime is bigger
than t
okay so um what you want to think about
is um
the
uh is when you when you have the case t
equals 0 because that should be the
usual finals inequality
in that case uh we
well the the neighborhood size is just
one so so nt is
um is the number of of uh of points
which are within some some radius of the
troop of the point in question um and
also so if t is equal to zero then
you'll see that um that this is
uh is the delta that leads to the two
delta separation of um of the
of the data of pvs
um
let me erase this because that didn't
help okay so
so the result um
is so the distance based
version
of the
[Music]
lower bound on minimax risk
is
is fee of
um delta of t
times 1 minus
mutual information between x and v
plus 1 divided by log
base 2 of
the size of the set divided by nt
where
v is an index
chosen uniformly
over the set b
and
x is distributed as p sub v okay so
um
right so again comparing this to the
usual finals method
the usual finals method
would have nt is equal to one so
everyone would be well separated there
would only be one guy in each
neighborhood set
then we would just have a log of the
size of the set
and everything would be two delta
separated so we would just have v of
delta there
but then what happens is because we're
not forcing the points to be well
separated
we lose a factor of
of v over nt in in the denominator
um so uh well hopefully i haven't
completely confused everybody by now but
um so this is this is a statement that
holds for differential privacy sorry for
um
for general minimax lower bounds and now
i'll state the theorem from um duchy so
here's the theorem
and the theorem says that the
locally differential private minimax
risk
satisfies r sub ldp of p
l alpha is bigger than or equal to
v of delta of t times one minus
n e to the alpha minus one squared
over
log base 2 of
set multiplied by another factor which
is also complicated
soup of
soup over all functions which are
uniformly bounded by one um i need to
move this over again
let's do this
greater than or equal to this guy uh
v
vv
squared of gamma
minus 1 over
log base 2 of
this guy
where we define
where phi v
which maps all the bounded functions on
x to r
is defined
by a
v v of gamma
equals integral over
x
gamma of x
times dpv
of x minus
dp bar of x
where as you might imagine p bar is the
mixture
of all of the distributions in our scent
okay
so just a couple comments and then let's
take the break
so this expression probably looks really
really ugly um but what i want you to do
is to compare this expression with the
version of fano's method that i stated
up here right so you'll see that
this quantity is basically this quantity
except
instead of this mutual information bound
i have um what's written here okay so
really there are kind of two components
to proving this result
so the first one is to show that
that the distance based version of final
is valid for minimax bounds and so this
is actually a paper that i think um
duchy wainwright and jordan had uh maybe
a few months before the paper on local
differential privacy came out so um
and then after that to show that for
um for ldp mechanisms so in that case
you're observing not x but you're
observing z right so so z is the locally
differentially private processed version
of x and what you want to show is that
um is that you can actually
write an upper bound on i of z x
where um
uh
well in terms of something and the
something will have of course something
about the distribution of x
under um the possible pvs that are
showing up in in the set that you're
that you're uh they've constructed
um and then what pops out as well is
extra factors of e to the alpha
okay so i think i'm not going to go over
the proof because i want to discuss how
this is used in an example
so let's just
end here for now and then maybe i'll
take questions and then we can take a
break and i'll keep going
[Applause]
great things playing um yeah i guess
there's let's take a few questions if
there are any
if you have a question i'll run over and
bring the mic to you
uh i was just curious um when you
consider gibson delta um differential
privacy notion that you introduced
earlier like for the very basic setup
how does the lower bond change
yeah so um
well maybe the easy answer is that um
you can
actually show that the the same lower
bound will hold as long as delta isn't
too big so
this lower bound is up here and um i
think
oh well okay so now it's going to be a
different delta but the same lower bound
will hold as long as the the delta
that's used to
so let's call it uh let's call it green
delta so as long as the green delta is
order of one over m then you should end
up with the same bound um and that's
because
when we're um
well well how do we use the epsilon
differential privacy it's in um and
using this hamming the fact that if the
having distance is small then the
probabilities don't change too much
um so when you go down to the derivation
um then we wanted to say that that the
probabilities don't change too much so
you'll get an extra slop of this delta
term
so as long as delta isn't too small then
it doesn't change the bound too much
okay but but that's a limitation of
thanos method so as discussed by the
authors by acharya at all in their paper
this doesn't work if delta is larger and
so they advocate using the other
versions of um of the bounds so their
paper is called aswad fano and the time
and they show how i think a
differentially private
analog basswood can be used when delta
is larger
any other any other questions
perfect so yeah let's take our our break
it looks like it's 10 39 so let's be
back here
at 10 59.
thanks again